a definite integral this time we're
going to use the substitution x equals
Ted theta and that gives us DX I D theta
be equal to SEC squared so that I can
change variable in a minute but I also
need to account for these boundaries so
when x equals 103 the angle that
corresponds to that is pi/6 and when x
equals 1 the angle that corresponds to
that for 10 anyway is PI on 4 okay now
I've got all my pieces I'm going to
substitute in here we go
my new boundaries are from PI on six to
PI on four then what you've got here
this DX is going to become a sec squared
theta D theta so I'll stick that on the
numerator there okay what am I going to
get on the bottom well that x squared is
going to turn into 10 squared and then
you've got square root of 1 plus 10
squared there okay
now this here is an identity that we
need to recognize 1 plus tan squared is
Sam square so when I do the square root
that's just going to give me do the
boundaries first that's just going to
give me SEC so I've got 10 squared here
and one lot of SEC there or with respect
to theta okay
so you can see that one of the sex will
cancel there you go okay and so now I've
got well what's useful here this is a 1
over cause on the top so that means the
cause is gonna cancel down here so I've
got these boundaries that are the same
okay what are you going to get this is
actually sine squared on cos squared but
one of the causes will cancel so I'm
going to get sine squared on just one
cause not cos squared okay there we go
almost there
I have all these boundaries in place
here I'm dividing by dividing cos so
that's the same as multiplying by cars
and now we're at a position where you
can see this is reverse chain rule
you've got COS theta and sine theta to
the power of negative two
but the useful things that cause theta
is just the derivative of sine of theta
and if you can't if you're not so sure
about that you can say you know you let
u equal sine theta so do you on D theta
equals close theta you could do the
substitution again but it's a bit of a
it's a bit longer the truth you've
already done one substitution up here so
I'm just going to go straight into the
fact that this is negative one on sine
theta sine theta to the power of
negative one because this is negative
two the powers come up once so there are
our boundaries as before and now I can
evaluate this thing this is going to be
minus one on side pile for minus minus
one on side pi on six this guy is 1 over
root 2 so his reciprocal would just be
root 2 I got a double negative happening
there this guy is a half so his
reciprocal that's just sure they will
just put him round the right way so that
everything's nice to me
and that's it another definite integral
that we could do with a trig
substitution and this is the one that
gets provided to us so we'll do the
derivative so we can change variable in
the integral in a second so that's going
to be the derivative of the inside there
will be sec square and then the power
reduced by one you also have to change
your boundaries so you've got x equals
more over here as a lower boundary that
gives you theta equals more naught as
well and you got x equals 1 which in
this case is Finnick was pi on four once
you stick one in there and solve okay so
now I've got all that pieces we can do
our substitution we're not from dr1
anymore or from naught to PI on four
then I've got a square root of x now I'm
just going to consider that as tan theta
because the square root has to be
positive and then you've got 1 plus 10
squared which is the actual just
standard substitution then now instead
of a DX all right
2 SEC squared 10 defeat up ok so I'm
gonna get this 2 squared feet up ok just
enough room right now you can see that
on the denominator here 1 plus 10
squared that's an identity that's just
sex squared so in fact I'm gonna kids
with that with that okay so now that
leaves you with 0 2 pi and 4 I'll stick
that to at the front because it's a
consonant in to worry about 10 times 10
that's 10 squared ok now 10 squared we
don't have a nice simple integral for
but we can use an identity to show that
it's equal to something that is namely
SEC squared minus 1 that's easy too I'm
doing you can get that identity from the
Pythagorean relationship then so SEC
squared integrates into 10 and negative
1 it degrades into theta from 2 pi and 4
okay so now I've got that 2 out the
front this is going to be 10 piled 4
minus 4 and when you evaluate both of
these 0 you just get 0 so I've got 10
pound 4 which is just 1 and that's just
the pilot for so you get 2 minus PI on
to ok last one for today I've got an
integral which I can do by substitution
and this is the one that they give us x
equals 4 sine squared theta so to change
variable I've got my DX 1 D theta over
here that is going to be this is sine
theta to the power of 2 so I'm going to
bring that to out the front I'm going to
reduce the power by 1 and then I'm going
to multiply by the derivative of the
inside function which was just sign it's
derivative is cos I also need to change
my batteries so x equals 0 over here the
angle that corresponds to that for this
will be
zero now when x equals two I better do
the working just to make sure I get this
right you get 2 equals 4 sine squared
theta so that means you've got sone
squared theta equals 1/2 and just taking
the positive case for this one I get
sine theta equals 102 so the angle that
corresponds to that is PI on 4 right so
now I can do all of my substitutions I'm
now from naught to PI on 4 and what I've
got underneath the square root is that's
the X term just there which is 4 sine
squared theta like they told us to put
in then you've got 4 minus 4 sine
squared theta and instead of DX I'm
gonna have kind of this this monstrous
thing in here I'm gonna run out of space
I can tell it's going to be multiplied
by 8 sine theta just put a continuing
down here cos theta D theta
okay so there's some some canceling
that's going to happen here for starters
this is sine squared up here and I've
got a cos squared down here okay but
they're they're going to be both by a
factor of 4 which I can cancel and
they're both going to be taking a square
root off so the squares will vanish so
that's why I'm going to go straight from
this to that's going to be signed over
cause that's it that's that's all this
whole square root thing evaluates to I
could write it that as tan but it's not
much point because what I want to do is
cancel immediately these are these close
terms I can see here kids saw canceled
okay good so I'll what I'll do is I'll
take I've got a side squared here I'm
gonna take I've got eight of them I'm
gonna take a factor of four out because
I still want to in the brackets like
this because that'll allow me to use my
double angle for cos in here and it's
simply for Row two point four it's one -
close to theater which you can verify by
expanding that and then you can
the relationship between these two okay
with respect to theta okay so now I'm in
a place where I can integrate so I've
got a four out there one turns into a
theta this is just gonna be a half side
to theater from naught to PI on four I
don't like that that half hang around
there so I'm just going to stick to
inside the brackets which will give me
this from naught to PI on four and now
I'll evaluate this guy I'm going to get
there's the two outside the front two
times pi and 4 is PI on - and I've got
so implanted - as well when you evaluate
both of these at zero you get zero okay
side pilot 2 is just 1 so this is going
to be 2 times pi 2 which is pi minus 2
times 1 which is 2 and that's it